Magnus Carlson nearly flagged a
classical game making a move with just
one second on the clock round six of
Norway chess saw Countryman Magnus
Carlson and aryantari face off the early
game saw a positional Advantage for tari
later Magnus had chances but missed them
under time pressure in fact Magnus
nearly lost on time oh and Magnus made
that move with one second left on the
clock the game soon finished in a draw
in Armageddon tari spiraled after taking
on F5 with his pawn and his position
continued to worsen afterwards oh and we
just see the evaluation bar slide in
favor of black Magnus knew he had a
Checkmate on the board it's over at the
very end Magnus almost made an illegal
move he wanted to checkmate with his
Rook but the Rook was pinned the victory
did not come without bumps as